when you get a script
that looks challenging and you know the
easiest thing to do is say it can't be
done
what made snowfall season three episode
one
a challenge for you
well what was most challenging about it
was how big it was meaning how many
huge sequences were scripted you know a
season premiere episode is needs to be
exciting it needs to pack a lot in to
kind of sustain audiences interest to
come back for future episodes and and in
season three uh it was one of the most
this this was a show in case your
viewers don't know about it which dealt
with the uh
crack cocaine epidemic in the early 80s
in south central los angeles and uh
there was so much packed into this uh
particular episode there were stunt
sequences there were aerial sequences
there was uh
deep interpersonal things going on
and
so
whenever i'm given a script to read uh
or that i'm going to direct i try to
read it at first
putting aside all those considerations
you know i was trying to first because i
you know one of the challenges i had
transitioning from being an assistant
director
to becoming a director is to stop being
an assistant director to stop looking at
something in terms of the difficulty to
do it but instead to look at how this
story is affecting me
how might i tell the most exciting
wonderful story exploring all of his
depths
you know as possible
and let myself dream about it
[Music]
and so i'll read a script just letting
it wash over me and seeing what
interests me determining what is it
really about what what am i drawn to in
the characters
because i can't really know how
difficult it is to shoot it within the
time and budget constraints until i
figure out what story i'm telling where
i want the emphasis to be how i'm going
to do certain things some things that
read difficult
as being difficult might be shot very
simply some things that seem simple
might be very very complicated to shoot
so uh
in this particular instance there was no
getting around that this was just a bear
of the show you know in my book
i do have a chapter oh great let me see
i think i summarize in it um
here's the book i think i think i
summarized what the issues were what the
sequences were
let's see
um
when i was hired to direct the opening
episode of the third season of the fx
show snowfall
i was presented with a script that
included an ambitious opening stunt
sequence on the streets of south central
l.a as well as a sprawling nighttime
shootout a shocking murder of one of the
recurring characters a bar fight an
aerial stunt sequence culminating in a
crash landing on a mexican airstrip a
grand opening celebration the rekindling
of a romantic of a romance between two
lead characters a lengthy nighttime
driving sequence ending in a nightmarish
reveal of a crack house plus many other
highly charged sequences it was a
well-written densely packed script and
it promised to be a great kickoff to the
season
but it was huge
so
snowfall
was on is on the fx network and that's a
basic cable channel it's not you know
the budget of snowfall is nothing like
things like game of thrones or the
marvelous mrs mazel where the production
values are opulence so
you know as as a director coming in any
show you have to accept
the givens what the limitations are and
the budget is one of the significant
ones
but
each show including snowfall is aspiring
for the same number of viewers you wanna
you know you wanna to to make it as
compelling as possible so
i did have to prep in order to figure
out how much we could do i had to prep
all of the various sequences and you
work in in conjunction with the
assistant director who's scheduling the
show as you're going and you try to find
out
originally what i what i initially what
i try to do is
get a sense of what would it take to
shoot this episode not like if you have
an eight-day schedule how do we fit this
into eight days
no i'd like a realistic
estimate of how many 12-hour days would
we need to shoot this entire script and
some assistant directors are reluctant
to do that because they feel their
bosses are wanting them you know just no
no say we can all do it but you know you
don't want to be put in a situation
where you can't succeed you don't want
to be put in a position to fail so the
show is the show it's a high quality
show so i know everybody wants it to be
good you're not going to be able to do
it badly so to do it up to the standards
of the show and up to my own standards
what would it take
and it might take well to do all of that
it's going to be 12 days
well okay we don't have 12 days or i
could then go to the producer and say
can you give me four more days to shoot
and they'll say no and then we'll say
okay
in this case they had given me actually
an extra day because they knew it was
big so it's a nine-day schedule but it
couldn't be done in the nine days and
so then my job as a director is
it's easy to say what can't be done the
real challenge and what distinguishes
one director from another is how much of
a scripps
real value and merit can you
can you realize within the limitations
you know how can you how can you find
other ways as
they say to skin the cat
so
the best way for me through that is a
focus always on story
be as prepared as i can be
and and see what what time savers i can
create that can allow us to do a little
bit more maybe than what you originally
thought so
in this instance
in the chapter i write about in my book
i focus on only one of the sequences but
it should be noted that this
i was prepping all of the sequences
simultaneously because you only have the
eight days to prep before you start
shooting
and uh this one sequence was very
complicated and it was the opening stunt
sequence
so in this opening scene
this was the transition from season two
to season three and what the writers
wanted to show was the effect that the
crack trade was beginning to have on the
community of south central los angeles
so we wanted we wanted to see a
transition from the previous season
and the
main character of this opening teaser
this opening stunt sequence
is a police officer
who
happens to be the father
of a young woman who is the girlfriend
of the drug dealing
protagonist of the series i guess you
would call him an anti-hero because he's
doing some pretty bad stuff
so he's got this internal family issue
that his daughter is is uh
is uh
his lovers with this drug dealer
and uh he's also committed to preserving
his community so what the epi what the
scene dramatizes is you start with him
patrolling south central
and he's seeing that there's signs of a
change you see young men on the corners
wearing gold chains you see others
driving cars that they didn't used to be
able to afford
and as he drives continues to drive he
sees a car stopped in the middle of the
street on a drug trade a drug deal going
down and there's a dealer in the car and
there's a young woman crack addict who's
leaning in the car window
trying to buy dope
so he pulls his car over walks towards
the
car
and the dealer sees him approach and
quickly tries to end the deal and says
to the woman get out of here
but another way to show the
the way this drug has taken hold of the
community
these the addicts of crack
are so dependent on it that she's she
can't take no for an answer so as he
starts to pull away she jumps in the car
window the open car window with half her
body outside legs flailing reaching for
the dope
as he's tearing off the policeman goes
back to his car tears off this is what's
written tears off after him after they
go a certain distance the woman
grabs some crack off the seat falls off
the car
collapses in an unconscious heap
the policeman comes up to her and
thinking she may be dead for all she he
knows he gets out of the car he comes
towards her and just as he's about to
reach down to her she leaps up
and tears off and again
meant to well whatever that she's got
this
she's energized by this crazy drug and
she wants to get high and she's she's
running away
again what's scripted she runs off and
she goes by a car
parked somewhere and she tears off its
antenna as she's going and she stuffs as
she's running she stuffs the crack into
the antenna i should say that was a note
john singleton who was uh who who lived
this story i mean in south central and
not that he was a crack addict but he he
cre he was one of the creators of the
show and and he he'd always wanted to
get this note in because he thought that
was kind of a cool thing that he had
actually seen someone taking an antenna
and making a crack pipe out of it so she
continues to run crap you know he the
policeman gives chase
and loses her and when he finally sees
in the corner we see her with inhaling
from the antenna pipe blissfully looking
at him content for him to take her
anywhere he wants
and the the end of the teaser is meant
is that he sees her and is aware
this drug is trouble this could ruin us
if this woman could go to these lengths
we're all in serious trouble all right
that was the scene
huge stunt sequence to do to do safely
and to do well and to cover a lot of
terrain and all that kind of stuff
so while i'm prepping the episode and
but it was also the kicker they lead
into the season so i really wanted to
deliver an exciting sequence
so
some of my considerations were these
well first of all while we're prepping
this we're prepping everything else too
so we're seeing how much time do we need
to do that and it felt to me like it was
a couple of days work to do this because
it was also in the height of winter so
we had about nine hours of daylight
and uh
there's lunch in between so to do all of
that car stuff to do a dangerous stunt
to do
traveling big areas to do running
through you know backyards and all that
stuff you know that's that's hugely time
consuming probably not doable in in
i mean two days would be a challenge to
do it and we didn't have time for that
so we're trying to figure out okay for
the aerial flight sequence we need this
for that we need this for the nighttime
thing we need this
and it was just obviously seeming very
big so the first thing and i was talking
to the showrunner about okay he was
interested in how i was doing because he
wanted as much in it as he could i said
well first let's think story here
this is a priority this this stunt
sequence obviously um some of these
other things we don't have time for i
don't think we have time for this aerial
sequence because first of all it's very
difficult to shoot that and secondly
it's not terribly important story wise
it's just what it dramatizes a pretty
minor story point it gooses it it makes
it kind of exciting but the story
totally gets told without that so we we
decided early on okay we'll get rid of
that but we still had far too much to do
but finally we nipped and tucked and we
did all that stuff until we got to the
point where we think we can i think i
can make just about everything else work
but the thing is we have to figure out a
way to do this son in one day
i can't we can't have more than one day
to do it
and then that became its own challenge
okay how can i possibly do this now
in trying to uh
give the opening sequence the magic i
really wanted it to have
the first two seasons the pilot episode
of the show had a beautiful uh opening
shot which was shot with an airborne
drone and it was you know in south
central l.a
there the there are a few streets that
are have these enormous beautiful thin
status palm trees that line the street
and this particular opening shot of the
whole series from the first season was a
beautiful shot that started on the
street and then it rose up and it rose
up and it revealed these incredible you
know
trees that kind of presided over the
life the lives of everybody below and i
wanted to invoke that to you know
say okay that was season one now we're
in the same place season three and
what's different so i thought okay first
we need to find
a street that has these because there
weren't that many that have those that
have those trees and also it has to be
appropriate for the period which was
1984. so if you know if there were
you know inappropriate architecture we
couldn't shoot there we were able to
find about two blocks that were really
good
weren't the only two blocks but they
were they were pretty good they were two
blocks but what was written was much
more than two blocks first of all you
have the guy the policeman circling the
whole community driving through it
establishing other things coming to
another area seeing this drug deal
parking his car on the side street
coming over to them the car taking off
him going back to his car racing god
knows how many blocks
and and and all that so he said okay
well that's going to be a challenge and
i also was struck by the story challenge
of
uh well i started i said okay
maybe what we could do is if we use
these two blocks and i can be invented
with my angles we can shoot them as if
they're many more blocks by changing our
angles having the car come in at
different places so we made a plan to do
that
then
the most important the biggest challenge
was how to do this very dangerous stunt
safely i mean you know the stunt like
that is exciting because it's
life-threatening to see somebody hanging
out of the car like that and you know
obviously we have to make it safe for
the stunt performers so how do we do
that so i had to i had to work with the
stunt coordinator and the cameraman and
we worked out kind of a way to shoot it
and a way to uh
bolt her in to have her connected to the
car when we see the car from the outside
she's she's not really she's has
something to hang on to but she also has
to jettison from the car too so it can't
be a belt so it was really i was very
concerned about doing it safely
and we and we figured out several things
one we figured that
i also needed i said i realized i need a
close-up of her falling away from the
car as well as a shot from outside the
car of her falling off
for a reason i'll talk about in just a
moment but what that pointed me to was
that i needed a stunt woman to be able
to play the part because i was going to
be on her close-up as she's trying to
get the drugs and her falling away onto
the street
so we had to find stunt people that
could possibly pull it off and we
fortunately did and i realized when we
had
her as a stunt person i said well maybe
if the stunt if the dealer could also be
a stunt man but there was real acting
involved so i had to audition several
stunt people until we found two people
that we thought could do it but that
created a real time saver in that we
didn't have to tow the car ever it could
be free driven the stuntman could always
drive the car himself
and uh we wouldn't have to put a car
connected to another insert car camera
car and tow it that's a big time drain
would have meant we couldn't do that
couldn't do the show couldn't do the
scene in its full way
so we'd save time that way then i
started to think about other issues it's
like now how does a this whole thing of
her running away how how does a
physically fit cop
lose someone running away who's right
there with her she starts running she
breaks off this thing she does all this
stuff he's giving chase how does he how
does she get enough distance to to lose
him
that didn't make much sense to me i mean
it can be done but it just you know it
would have felt to me like a big cheat
so i suggested well why don't we instead
of having the cop
go back to his car and give chase what
if he just runs after the car that's
going off and and then she'll fall off
after one block which will shorten the
amount of terrain we have to cover
and will also make him winded when he
gets there which might justify him not
being able to give chase
so that also
enabled us to have to do a whole company
move to shoot the end of the car chase
it would just be right on our same two
blocks all right we did that
um
it's it's really
an epic story i hope
people are still following me but
everything that goes into these scenes
you see it's like it's uh i think some
viewers sometimes just watch a show as
if oh yeah that happened and you don't
realize how many choices go into every
sequence you watch and how many
decisions are being made to
present the scene in exactly the way you
see it because everything is a choice
in any case uh we started working on it
uh
more and i realized okay this still
isn't working and i realized the thing
in terms of the time we still can't do
this in one day and i realized the
bridge too far was this second chase
and i went to i went to the showrunner
and i asked him what are
tell me about which is something i all
like to do a great deal of is to really
confer with the writers a lot to find
out everything they had in mind i mean
i'll have my own take on the material
and i'll try to bring my own values and
and resources to bear but i really wanna
i'm really assisted by hearing from the
writers what exactly was in their mind
what what is the subtext what did they
really whose point of view is the scene
what were you really working on
and the writer the showrunner a guy
named dave andron very talented was
saying well
i really want to show
the depths to which these crack addicts
will go to get their fix and als and
that's really why all this stuff is
happening
and i thought okay so that's that's what
we want to show and i thought do we
really need because the thing that was
adding to the time was her springing up
and running through backyards and back
alleys and him running and imagining
getting the camera and also having to do
tight insert shots of what she's doing
while she's running namely packing the
pipe it just would be a real real
challenge to do quickly
and i thought you know maybe there's a
way that everything can happen at the
first stop
but how can we make it
deliver that same sense and so i came up
with this idea which i pitched to dave
i said what if she falls
falls and uh rolls behind a car so that
only her back legs are visible to the
policeman running up to her and those
back legs are inert aren't moving
so we think is she dead is she
unconscious and when he gets up to her
she could turn to him we didn't see her
loading the crack pipe and she turns to
him exhaling oh she could already have a
crack pipe why does she's an addict
couldn't she just have her own pipe why
does she have to break off an antenna
and so you know you lose a little bit of
you know interesting color and a note
and john singleton you know was sad to
see it go but you know he got it and uh
um
and that she could just simply turn to
him when he's expecting to see her
you know
really harmed from this terrible spill
you know blissfully happy and then we
could rely on his face to tell the whole
story so with some reluctance dave the
showman said okay i get it all right so
now we had a plan if everything went
perfectly we might be able to get this
all in one day uh but i also needed in
addition to that stunt i needed to shoot
everything that preceded it and i wanted
an elegiac kind of oh it's the right
word a legend i don't know opening shot
that would recall that so it's like as
as he's going through the neighborhood i
wanted a shot that somehow would see
these tall
palm trees and all that and i thought
should we mimic the drone shot that was
in the first episode
but i thought better of that because i
thought that's not the story the story
is i mean i want to evoke that episode
but the story here is the policeman's
point of view of what's happening in
this community so what i elected to do
instead was to start with a camera
mounted on the roof of the top of the
cop car
looking up we don't know where we are
traveling down the street seeing these
palms go by and then tilt down and end
over the light bar of the police car
so it would so that then we'd cut inside
and we understand we were in the point
of view of the policeman
so we would evoke those palm trees and
that world but we'd establish what the
story is which is this is this man's
point of view so all of these things i'm
collecting and all that and trying to
figure out how we're going to get done
and i it worked out with the cameraman
efficient ways to shoot uh you know
shooting and and one way that we
realized we could do that was what you
call chasing the backlight always
shooting into the sun so that you're
going to get nice lighting so that we'd
start you know shooting directionally
one way
instead of you know when you're not
shooting in the backlight sometimes uh
directors of photography need to
artificially create that which means
lighting and the sun is the best
backlight you can use and it's also the
quickest trying to minimize how much
lighting we used
anyway so after we figured all this work
that how the stunt could be done safely
and all that stuff we're ready to shoot
and i did a shot list and
when i showed up on the day of shooting
my sister rector said you know i've done
a timing and i think we're only going to
get through about two-thirds of the
shots before we lose the light
so i heard him and i said okay but i i
wasn't convinced but i was concerned
and i just said well let's let's stick
with the plan and let's go and i just
made sure to move on as soon as i had
what i needed not get perfection but get
what we needed
and i probably barked a little more than
usual to make sure everybody was
anticipating okay what's up next what's
up next we also got two identical period
cars 1984 cars so that we could
rig uh which isn't easy when you're
dealing with period cars so that we
could rig the interior
the shot the the
shots that were required to be inside
the car on the characters
we could rig lights on it
and keep another car free of any of
those lights so that we could just jump
from one to another when we're shooting
outside the car and see the car go by we
did all those kind of things you do and
experienced crews knows to do and you
accomplish that in prep so we started
shooting
and uh it was going very well and we got
you know we got deep into the stunt and
everything was kind of working nicely
and um
then we got to the point where we had to
do the
young woman's hurtling off the car
and
uh as i mentioned before it was kind of
critical where she landed because she
needed to land behind half wheel half
her legs out visible and half in front
and i realized how difficult that is the
stunt man was the stunt coordinator an
excellent stunt coordinator but as some
stunt coordinators do they can sometimes
overestimate what their people can do
and he said oh she's going to be able to
hit that
and i kind of
okay and we started doing the fall the
shot of the car going by and her
hurdling herself off of it so the car sh
was meant to look like it was going very
fast because he was trying to avoid the
policeman
and he couldn't go that fast because she
was going to have to time her jump and
it was also not as safe if he needed to
slow down a little bit so i did what we
call under crank the camera so that it
would look a little faster and it would
make her her fall look a little more
herky-jerky and more dangerous too
and we shot the scene and shot the shot
and uh the first check just didn't work
she just it didn't work she just
fell completely wrong and it's okay take
one no good let's do another one
and the second one we did and she did a
great fall
problem is she didn't land anywhere near
the
behind the car
and i'm sitting everything with the sun
getting lower and all of us you know
banking on finishing this day and aware
of how much work had still to be done
including the the opening shot of the
sequence which we're going to wait till
the sun was at its lowest to get a
beautiful backlight for this other thing
i knew i had to get to that too
i thought i can't ask this stunt woman
to do this again she really
did a great job at
skidding across a pavement
you know even if you're wearing pads
it's got to be painful and a lot of
injuries can happen when you do
unnecessary additional takes of stunts
so i said you know what at least she had
landed with her
uh
facing away from
the policeman so i said you know what
i'll figure something out let's just say
it's fine
and we started to move on and uh
and then i did a shot of uh
over the inert body
teddy cam to get some energy to tie them
together as the policeman's running
towards her i go past her and meet the
policeman coming up
and i told her on the ground i said
don't move until i tell you that we're
past you because i don't want to tip
that you're still alive
and we did that and then i did a shot
over the charging policeman towards her
and i told her wait till i cue you to
turn around
because i wanted him to get closer to
her and the first take we did she
thought she heard my cue too early
and as he starts to run she starts to
make some movement
and i said okay
wait that was a miscue you didn't hear
that wasn't really me let's do it again
and she did it how i wanted her to do it
so we finished the sequence i'll talk
about that later but i'll jump to this
that night i was after the day it
completed i thought successfully i
bolted up in bed because i realized oh
my god i made a terrible mistake
i
if she hasn't moved at all until he gets
there there's no way she could turn to
him and exhale this pipe how would she
have lit it how would that have happened
and i thought did i
well i could do it in cuts but it would
just be a far inferior sequence you
wouldn't get any of the excitement of
seeing them all in the frame and all
that
and i was beside myself until i
remembered
the miscue when she turned a little too
early
and i thought okay it's saved it won't
be exactly as i thought but i can still
have the dynamic shots and an audience
will believe when they see her turning
with the lid pipe that they'll they
won't be bumped they'll still be with
the story so a mistake had led to my
salvation so that's the kind of thing
you got to be present to what's
happening so you can see opportunities
that you know you may have missed
anyway so we completed the sequence and
i should say too because it may be of
interest to those of you who
are interested in editing that the
reason i needed the shot in close-up and
the sh of her falling away from the car
which by the way she fell onto a camera
platform on the car she didn't go on we
didn't want her to hurt herself by doing
that unnecessarily so we had a camera
platform
below you couldn't see when she dropped
out she just dropped onto a platform
and
joining that to the shot of her
the shot outside
she couldn't really create the necessary
spring she needed to get all the way
across the lane unless she kind of
jumped but that's not what it was
supposed to look like it was supposed to
look like she was a rag doll and just
had fallen off
but by having the close-up angle of her
i was able to stitch together two shots
where i could go from the close-up angle
of her falling out of the frame and cut
out the false beat of her starting the
jump from the exterior shot so we could
just cut to her being a rag doll falling
away and rag dolling all the way over so
that was the reason for the need for the
for the two angles of the stunt in any
case
um
i i i'm hesitant to go much further i do
detail this in the book we ended the day
racing to get the opening sequence which
was a complicated
shot as well because
it involved timing the background cue
we're moving down the street seeing
these beautiful trees coming down over
the
light bar seeing the street and i needed
a few things to happen that would
justify a convertible car which was a
story point
going by that we had a second camera in
the passenger seat of the car so that
then panned with the car going by ending
in a profile shot of the cop which was
revealing okay it's that guy
and this is his scene
and we were racing to get it the
everything was in place and we but the
sun was sinking
we tried it a couple times the timing
didn't quite work and we really only had
one last chance to get it with optimal
lighting conditions which i really cared
about because it was quite beautiful
and i was sitting in the back seat of
the car with the operator with a
handheld monitor because it came because
the camera angles were on top of the
roof and also in the seat in front of me
looking forward and we said one last
shot and we this is i love this because
it shows you how collaborative and how
many how people bring so many talents to
bear to make something great
and uh we started our trip down the uh
down the road and we're seeing and i'm
looking at the monitor and you're seeing
these beautiful trees going by and i'm
thinking this guy should pan down sooner
he should tilt down we're going to get
we're going to miss the queue we're
going to miss the queue and it felt to
me too long and he had his own intuition
and he kind of tilted down iq background
action and it was just perfect and we
had this beautiful introduction
and we finished it and it was just uh
one of those great feelings of
accomplishment and it's
you know it so that when you get a
script
that looks challenging and you know the
easiest thing to do is say can't be done
you know but what's really great is to
is is when you do pull it off by ex and
and don't don't
resign yourself to telling a story less
well you know you can still find
you know you can still if you really
stay fiercely committed to telling the
story and getting everything out of it
you possibly can you have you have a
real chance often
to really pull something off that
doesn't look very possible